Greta Gerwig is bringing Barbie to life
on the big screen but is a movie about a
doll just toying around or will it
somehow break the mold here's all you
need to know before checking out the
latest toy turned Blockbuster
if you're a movie lover then you've no
doubt circled July 21st on your calendar
after all it's the most important day of
2023. why is that how about because this
is the most important thing to ever
happen in the history of the world on
that day two phenomenal films will hit
theaters at the same time and go head to
head for box office dominance July 21st
will play host to Barbie a colorful zany
comedy and Christopher Nolan's
Oppenheimer a grim heavy biopic
regardless of which film does better
it's a win-win for cinephiles as both
films look like they're going to be
absolutely exceptional
when it comes to the movie's plot the
official Barbie website has provided a
short but sweet summary which reads to
live in Barbie land is to be a perfect
being in a perfect place unless you have
a full-on existential crisis or you're a
can unfortunately for our ever smiling
hero it looks like she's having that
crisis in the film's official main
trailer we see how her perfect life is
falling apart her morning shower is
ruined by a sudden surge of cold water
while she used to easily float down from
the roof of her house into her cute
Barbie car now she's just falling
straight to the ground and instead of
feet that always perfectly mimic the
shape of a high heel shoe suddenly her
soles are flat on the ground the horror
most alarming of all Barbie is suddenly
haunted by thoughts of death hoping to
find answers to Life's big questions she
decides to venture out into the real
world with a stowaway Ken tagging along
unfortunately this is frowned upon by
the executives at Mattel the company
that makes Barbie toys when our blonde
hero leaves Barbie land behind the suits
do everything in their power to hunt her
down will they put her back in the Box
before Barbie can figure her life out
the trailers for Barbie have all been
pretty incredible the first Barbie
teaser was a hilarious homage to 2001 A
Space Odyssey with a tribe of little
girls ditching their baby dolls when a
gigantic Barbie shows up on the scene
standing in for 2001's Erie monolith the
second Barbie teaser got even zanier
complete with Beach Boys Tunes the
bright pink Hues of Barbie land and
every character greeting are bubbly
blonde protagonist hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Barbie however it's the film's main
trailer that really drives home the plot
showing the cracks that are starting to
show in Barbie's seemingly perfect life
with thoughts of death swirling around
her head Barbie is given a matrix-like
choice by Kate McKinnon's character she
can either pick the high heel and stay
in her regular life or pick the sandal
and go on a journey of exploration after
a bit of prodding Barbie and Ken set out
on a highly stylized Journey to the real
world of course as the trailer shows the
real world is no Cakewalk Barbie even
winds up in jail however as she searches
for meaning Barbie never gives up hope
and the trailer promises that this wacky
comedy is going to go to some serious
places ideas live forever
Barbie features one of the best casts
we've seen in a long time Margot Robbie
stars as the titular doll which is
perfect casting as she looks exactly
like Barbie and since Robbie has played
wildly varied characters in projects
like The Suicide Squad I Tonya and Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood we know her
spin on the iconic character will be
something unique of course you can't
have Barbie without Ken and Ryan Gosling
is stepping into the role of the blonde
boy toy which is another casting Triumph
since Gosling looks like a walking
talking Kendall and while he excels at
playing quiet brooding men he's also
great at over-the-top comedy as
evidenced by the nice guys I had to
question the mermaids what were you
doing while I was working as for the
rest of the cast this is where things
get incredibly funny most of the
actresses are all playing different
versions of Barbie and most of the
actors are playing various versions of
Ken for example Issa Ray is President
Barbie Ritu Arya is a Pulitzer
prize-winning Barbie and Dua Lipa is
mermaid Barbie playing a whole host of
cans whose defining characteristic seems
to be the fact that they're all just
cans we've got simulio Kingsley benedir
shuti gatwa and Scott Evans just to name
a few cans Michael Sarah of Arrested
Development Fame also lives in Barbie
land but he's a bit of an oddball
instead of playing a Ken Sarah is
playing Alan a character based on a
discontinued 1960s toy that was made to
be Ken's best friend similarly
oscar-winning screenwriter Emerald
fennel will play Midge another less
famous toy who was at one point
canonically married to Alan rounding
things out Will Ferrell will play the
CEO of Mattel Helen Mirren will narrate
the movie Ray Pearlman of Cheers Fame
will also show up and famed wrestler
turned actor John Cena will reportedly
appear as a merman
Barbie marks Greta gerwig's third film
as a director but while she's only
helmed three movies gerwick is one of
the most exciting filmmakers in
Tinseltown she first sat down behind the
camera for ladybird the coming-of-age
dramedy that earned multiple Oscar
nominations including one for best
picture and two for Gerwig best director
and best original screenplay she then
reunited with sir sharonan for a beloved
adaptation of Little Women which earned
a best picture nod at the Academy Awards
and also nabbed Gerwig an Oscar
nomination for best adapted screenplay
in other words when Gerwig gets involved
with the project you can bet that film
will turn out to be gold even a concept
as crazy as Barbie while a guest on Dua
lipa's podcast At Your Service Gerwig
talked about her experience making the
upcoming film saying it was terrifying
that feeling that I had was knowing that
it would be really interesting Terror
usually that's where the best stuff is
anything where you're like this could be
a career Ender then you're like okay I
probably should do it Gerwig also wrote
the script alongside Noah bomback her
romantic partner similar to Gerwig
bombek is also a highly respected
director having helmed movies like
marriage story and the squid and the
whale
the Barbie Dream House is a legendary
estate and the Barbie movie design team
has done the palace extra proud and
extra pink production design and set
decoration Dream Team Sarah Greenwood
and Katie Spencer Drew inspiration from
mid-century modern mansions and
real-life toys plus director gerwig's
references which according to
architectural digest ranged from the
Bold Pee-wee's Big Adventure to the
pastel-powered fever dream of An
American in Paris the result is a dream
house that looks like Mad Men meets
Nicki Minaj the design of the dream
house is inspired by The Kaufman house a
Palm Springs home designed in 1946 by
Richard Neutra while neutra's work
favors neutral Shades Greenwood and
Spencer had a mandate of their own to
follow think pink the team used so much
pink paint it caused an international
shortage but not all of that paint was
on the Dream House itself the beautiful
backdrops that surround Barbie land are
hand-painted not CGI partly in keeping
with what Gerwig calls the authentic
artificiality of Barbie's World the home
is full of bright colors and toy-like
details even Barbie's Closet is clearly
designed to match the packaging of
clothes sold separately still a quick
glance at Barbie's movie home shows that
there is a price to be paid for living a
perfect life Gerwig explained to
architectural digest dream house is
assume that you never have anything you
wish was Private there is no place to
hide
Barbie and Batman have a lot in common
names that start with b extreme wealth
and style absentee parents so it only
makes sense that they also share the
same taste in automobiles the Barbie
movies dream car was designed by the
same artists who made the Batmobile for
Robert Pattinson's the Batman well this
Baddie collaboration has us hoping for
an influx of street legal hot pink
Batmobiles we won't hold our breath
unless it's for another potential
electric and real-life Barbie car Titan
Barbie's movie Ride is a custom pink
electric Corvette eagle-eyed viewers of
the Barbie trailers can spot an electric
charging port and a blue highlighted EV
in the Chevrolet script on the side of
the dream car when Fox News reached out
to Chevrolet regarding possible
real-life Barbie cars Chevrolet provided
a response Barbie and Corvette have had
a long-standing relationship and we're
excited to build on that in the Barbie
movie more to come on this and some
other surprises Auto Evolution reports
that GM has confirmed that electric
Corvettes are slated for release soon so
why shouldn't some be Pretty in Pink
Barbie and pink go together like well
Barbie and Ken but production design and
set decorator collaborators Sarah
Greenwood and Katie Spencer had to get
the right pinks for the Barbie movie
pinks that would sustain the dreaminess
of Barbie's World as well as convey the
playful toy-like quality of her real
life finding the perfect pink was no
easy task the designers narrowed their
scope from 100 pinks to a range of 10 to
build the look of the film according to
Indie wire Gerwig named the color
palette technobarby in reference to
Technicolor a suite of film color
processes that was popular with movie
musicals like The Wizard of Oz and the
red shoes Rodrigo Prieto who shot
Brokeback Mountain and the Irishman is
no stranger to colorful films he also
shot The Wolf of Wall Street and broken
Embraces his Artistry across Styles is
put to use by the Barbie movie while we
barely get a glimpse of the real world
in the Barbie movie one thing's for sure
when Barbie's there she's not in pink
Kansas anymore
the only way Barbie can have a giant
party with planned choreography and a
bespoke song every night in Barbie land
is with a stacked soundtrack so far
Nicki Minaj I spice lizzo kid Leroy
hayam Charli XCX Tame Impala Ava Max
Dominic Fike Carol G Pink Panthers and
5050 are confirmed to Grace the
soundtrack with their pink and Powerful
presences maybe we'll even get more of
Aqua than the sample used in the movie
trailer implies the album is executive
produced by hitmaker Mark Ronson who
personally requested Dua lipo work on a
song for a major set piece in the movie
according to his own Instagram post Mark
Ronson dm'd Dua Lipa a request to work
on the movie calling the movie hilarious
do a song will score a 60-person dance
scene in the movie dance the night also
has its own music video featuring a
cameo by Greta Gerwig while the Barbie
news themed Barbie the album cover
promises more Barbies and Ken's to be
announced there's one more Ken musician
we're excited about the kennest Ken of
them all Ryan Gosling while this might
shock some fans of the actor others
might be familiar with his musical side
from La La Land and larsent the Real
Girl or his former band Dead Man's Bones
real ones no goslings come a long way
from his Mickey Mouse Club days even if
his Ken costumes beg to differ
every interview Ryan Gosling grants
about playing Ken in the Barbie movie is
better than the last even though
according to the movie Ken's job is just
Beach Gosling had a hard time getting a
handle on his character at first he told
the crowd at cinemacon I didn't know Ken
from within and if I'm being really
honest I doubted Mike energy I didn't
see it but Margot and Greta they
conjured this out of me somehow it was
like I was living my life and then one
day I was bleaching my hair shaving my
legs wearing bespoke neon outfits and
rollerblading down Venice Beach Gosling
also spoke at cinemacon about how Robbie
helped him tap into his elusive energy
saying she left a pink present with a
pink bow from Barbie to Ken every day
while we were filming they were all
beach related like puka shells or a sign
that says pray for serve if Gerwig and
Robbie helped Gosling achieve internal
mental Ken Fitness he was on his own to
attain Ken's considerable physical
fitness which was no mean feat the Kent
life is it's that's it's even harder
than the gray man life I think
for the Barbie movies release the
Brand's iconic aesthetic inspired a
fashion trend called Barbie core think
like neon pink and playful poppy
aesthetic that leans into Frills girly
energy and all things toy-like and
fabulous a quick search of Barbie core
on Tick Tock returns gazillions of views
on posts featuring looks popping with
pink pastel Shimmer magenta fuchsia neon
the pink skies the limit Vogue reports
that the look has taken over Runway
Fashion as well especially with
versace's recent sparkling and movie
ready Fashions tourism boards are taking
advantage of the sudden interest in
Barbie core as well with California
creating a Barbie core tour through
California campaign for those who prefer
their pink with a touch of 60s inflected
style some Barbie core is even a direct
result of the meadow world of the movie
when Barbie leaves behind Barbie land
for the real world she and Ken skate
through Venice Beach on skates they
brought from home based on the iconic
Blades of 90s Barbies Impala skate is
releasing tie-in skates and pads that
exactly match the ones Barbie and Ken
wear in the movie soon real life Barbies
and Ken's can buy their own to live
their own plastic and fantastic Barbie
core lifestyle if they aren't all
already sold out
Issa Ray who plays President Barbie in
the Barbie movie is a legendary writer
director actor and producer known for
making and starring in hit shows like
insecure Rey knows a thing or two about
creating powerful pop culture and good
leadership Rey has openly praised the
energy and Leadership on the Barbie set
Ray told pop sugar literally everybody
on that set was just great Vibes great
to be around it starts at the top you
have two people your lead and your
director who are both women I must say
they're just both incredible people and
Incredibly talented they made it a
comfort zone initially Rey wasn't fully
on board with gerwig's pitch for the
Barbie movie just the director's
enthusiasm for the idea but when Rey got
to the script she told The Hollywood
Reporter reading it was like oh my God I
love her even more and then actually
shooting it it was incredible one of my
favorite experiences
Will Ferrell plays the CEO of Mattel in
the film who so far looks like the
movie's villain while Farrell isn't
exactly a victim of CEO type casting
this isn't the first time Farrell has
played a slightly villainous
institutional figure that breaks the law
of reality while wearing a suit and tie
Farrell plays a dad who just doesn't
understand his kid in The Lego Movie
until of course his kid and his Lego
remind him of the power of play his
costume for Barbie is incredibly similar
to that in The Lego Movie except in
Barbie his tie is pink of course perhaps
the movie's themes share a common thread
Farrell has also played the wildly
creative fashion designer Overlord
mugatu the silly and villainous
character in Zoolander Farrell is good
at playing over-the-top yet grounded
characters whether in suit and tie or
oat Couture he adored being in Barbie
telling the Wall Street Journal it's a
loving homage to the brand and at the
same time couldn't be more satirical
just an amazing comment on male
patriarchy and women in society and why
Barbies criticized and yet why every
little girl still wants to play with
Barbie
Barbie has been in development for a
long time first with Amy Schumer set to
Star and later with Anne Hathaway
attached sometime after that Margot
Robbie and her husband's production
company Lucky chap scooped up the
property while it might seem obvious
that Robbie would consider herself an
iconic blonde for the role of an iconic
blonde she actually wasn't her own First
Choice Robbie tells The Hollywood
Reporter about lucky chap we never
started a company to be a starring
vehicle for me we wanted to expand what
female stories and female storytellers
could do in this industry and I don't
need to be on screen for that to happen
so it tracks that Robbie initially
thought Gal Gadot would be a perfect fit
for the role of the beautiful sweet and
super sincere doll Robbie tells Vogue
Gal Gadot is Barbie energy she's so
genuinely sincere and she's so
enthusiastically kind that it's almost
dorky it's like right before being a
dork
well the story of the Barbie movie has
been kept mostly mysterious leading up
to its release it's clearly meant to be
a magical existential tale meant to
appeal to kids and adults while Gerwig
and the rest of the cast and crew have
playfully only teased that Barbie is
going to subvert expectations Greta has
shared some of her more philosophical
Inspirations a trip to Mattel and an old
book Gerwig tells Vogue about meeting
the many versions of Barbie at Mattel
all of the dolls are Barbie and Barbie
is everyone philosophically I was like
well now that's interesting the amount
and variety of Barbie's inspired Gerwig
who said it gave her an expansive idea
of self that we could all learn from
Gerwig also shared with Vogue that a
parenting guidebook she read as a kid
Reviving Ophelia kept coming up when she
was writing Barbie the book is about
raising teenage girls and the depression
they may face during the changes of
adolescence Gerwig related that to
Barbies saying how is this journey the
same thing that a teenage girl feels all
of a sudden she thinks oh I'm not good
enough you guys ever think about dying
Margot Robbie and Greta Gerwig know that
Barbie as a toy is beloved and beheaded
in equal measure Barbie is a significant
cultural figure sometimes for good and
sometimes for bad she is a symbol of
empowerment adventure and acceptance as
well as at times body image issues
impossible beauty standards and vapidity
Robbie and Gerwig decided to use all of
that in their movie Robbie told Vogue we
have to acknowledge that there are a lot
of people who aren't fans of Barbie they
actively hate Barbie and have a real
issue with Barbie we need to find a way
to acknowledge that while it remains to
be seen exactly how the not so sparkly
side of Barbie will be handled in the
movie The thoughtful and playful sound
bites sound promising the sense of play
the entire creative team has been
showcasing has audiences feeling like
kids again